we're just a few months out from Mass  Effect Andromeda but a new trailer is  here to help make the wait a little  easier I'm Tony and this is your  cinematic gamespot news update the new  trailer gives us a better glimpse at our  squad mates we've got to humans Liam  Kosta and Cora Harper PB via sorry and  drag the krogan we also get a look at  the female turian vetro and a glimpse of  the ark on the leader of the new evil  ket race some other shots give us a look  at another new alien race and some gun  combat it's a lot to take in Mass Effect  Andromeda is coming to ps4 xbox one and  pc on march 21st in the u.s. march 23rd  in the UK if you want to dig deeper  check out our discussion on whether or  not the game is being rushed on the  lobby gamespot's weekly live show and  for all the latest on mass effect you're  already in the right place  you